[sirens wailing
in the distance]
[ominous music]
♪
[gun cocks]
- WHAT? WHAT? WHAT?
WHAT? WHAT? WHAT?
CHECK YO'SELF,
BEFORE I BODY PIERCE
YOUR DAMN SKULL.
- THINK YOU CAN PULL THAT
TRIGGER 'FORE I BLOW
YOUR PERSONALITY OUT THE BACK
OF YO' HEAD?
THEN GO RIGHT AHEAD AND TEST
THE HYPOTHESIS
AND SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
- A'IGHT, I'MA GIVE YOU
A STRAIGHT-UP
VAMPIRE "C"-SECTION,
LIKE WE WAS...
both: EDWARD AND BELLA.
- HOLD UP.
YOU LIKE TWILIGHT?
- YEAH, I LIKE TWILIGHT,
[bleep].
YOU LIKE TWILIGHT?
- [bleep], TWILIGHT'S
MY JAM.
- YOU A EDWARD [bleep]
OR A JACOB [bleep]?
- ANSWER THAT [bleep]
TOGETHER.
THREE, TWO, ONE.
both: EDWARD.
- SHI...
- ARE YOU [bleep]ING
WITH ME?
- YOU EITHER PLAYING
SOME [bleep]ED-UP GAME,
OR YOU ARE STRAIGHT-UP
INSIDE MY HEAD.
- YO, AND WHEN YOU SAID
YOU WAS GONNA BLOW
MY PERSONALITY
OUT THE BACK OF MY HEAD,
I'M LIKE,
"THAT SOUNDS LIKE SOME [bleep]
I WOULD SAY."
- PSH.
- AND NOW THIS TWILIGHT [bleep]?
- IT'S WAVELENGTH, [bleep].
- SO I GUESS WE FRIENDS THEN.
- OH, WE BEST FRIENDS NOW.
WE THE BEST OF FRIENDS!
- BFFs?
- WE ARE BFFs, M.F.
[happy music]
♪
- [laughing]
- NO, YOU DIDN'T!
NO, YOU DIDN'T.
- YES, I DID!
- [laughing]
THAT IS A CRA--
THAT'S A CRAZY STORY, MAN.
[both laughing]
WHEW, TOO MUCH, BOY.
- [wheezing]
[coughing]
[gasps]
[sad music]
- [chokes]
[gasping]
TEAM...
EDWARD.
♪
[siren blips]
- MM, MM, MM.
- WELL, LOOKS LIKE
ANOTHER GANG-RELATED KILLING.
- [chuckles]
SURPRISE, SUR-MOTHER[bleep]ING-
N[bleep]-PRISE.
[chuckles]